you are an incredibly successful
scientist engineer architect artist
designer you've mentored a lot of
successful people can you give advice to
young people listening to this
how to have a successful career
and how to have a successful life look I
think there's
this beautiful line in Sheltering Sky
how many times have you seen a full moon
and
um in your life and actually took the
time to ingest and explore and reflect
upon the full moon probably 20 I believe
he says
um I I spend time with a full moon
I take my time with a full moon and I
pay attention to a full moon
and I think paying attention
to the seasons and taking time to
appreciate
um the little things the simple things
is what makes a meaningful life
uh I I was very lucky to have had you
know to have grown up in a home that
um
taught me this way of being my my
parents my grandmother who played a very
important role in in my growing up
um
and
and that ability to pay attention
and to be present is so so so so so I
could not emphasize it
uh enough is so crucial
um and be grateful and be grateful yeah
I think gratitude and presence
um appreciation uh really
um the the the most important things in
life if you could take a short tangent
about your grandmother
who's played a big role in your life
what uh what do you remember what what
lessons have you learned from her
she had this blanket that she would give
me every time I came back from school
and say you know do your homework here
and and meet with your friends here and
it was always in her garden and her
Garden in my mind was ginormous but when
I you know last I went there and saw the
site which has now become the site for
another
tall building it was a tiny tiny little
garden
um that that to me seemed so large when
when I was
um growing up because it it had
everything it had
um
it had fig trees it had olive trees it
had mushrooms it had the blanket I would
do my homework there it was everything
and I needed nothing nothing else
and
um and and that was my Garden of Eden
that was my childhood being and she
taught me you know you know we would lie
on the blanket and look at the clouds
and reflect upon the shapes of the
clouds and study the shapes of the
plants and there was a lot of wonder in
that childhood
um with her and and she taught me the
the
importance of Wonder uh in in sort of in
an eternal childhood and and living
adulthood as as a child and and so I I'm
very very grateful for that I think it
is the sense of wonder
um
the uh um speaking up was always
something that she adhered to to speak
up your Truth uh to be straightforward
um to be positive that these are things
that I also got from my mom
um
and for my mom the sense of humor she
she had the best sense of humor of uh
that that I could think of and and was
just
um just a joy to be around and and my
father taught me everything my father
taught me everything I know my mom
taught me everything I feel that's a
good but my grandma taught me everything
I Insight well I I see the sense of
wonder that just carries through
everything you do so I I think you would
you make your grandmother proud
uh well what about advice for how to
have a career
so you've had a very interesting career
and a successful career but not not an
easy one it took you took a few leaps I
did take a few leaps and they were
uncomfortable my father and I'll never
um forget
I think we were like listening to a
rolling stone song in the kitchen and my
dad
uh was actually born in Boston he's
American
um
he said
uh
I I started to have sort of these second
thoughts about continuing my education
in Israel and I wanted to you know go I
I was on my way to London to the
architectural Association to do my
diploma studies there
and he looked at me and he said get out
of here kiddo gotta get out of here
and you know you've outgrown where where
you're at you need to you know you need
to move forward another thing he had
taught me
um the feeling of discomfort as you as
you say the feeling of loneliness and
discomfort is is is
imperative to growth uh growth is
painful period any form of growth is
difficult and painful birth is difficult
and painful
um and and it is really really important
to place yourself in situations of
discomfort I like to be in a room where
everyone in the room is more intelligent
than me I like to be in those in that
kind of state where the people that I
surround myself with are
orders of magnitude more intelligent
than I am and I can say that that is
true of all of my team members and
that's the intellectual discomfort that
I feed off of the same is true for for
physical exertion
um you gotta put yourself in these
uncomfortable
um situations in order to grow in order
to find Comfort
um and then
on the other hand is is love is finding
finding love and finding that
um
you know that human this other human
that complements you and that makes you
a better version
uh of the one you are and even of the
one you want to be but with gratitude
and and attention and love you can go so
so far to the younger generation I don't
speak of a career I never thought of
um
my work as my career ever and there was
this constant entanglement between life
and work and love and longing and being
and mothering it's all the same
and uh I appreciate that to some people
that doesn't work in their you know in
in their
arrangement of of will versus
um comfort uh versus the reality but for
me it has always worked so I I think
to the younger generation I say don't
think of
your career career is something that is
imposed upon you think of your calling
that's something that's innately and
directionally
um
moves you and it's something that
transcends a career similarly you can
think about the difference between
you know learning versus being educated
being educated something that's given to
you that's external that's being imposed
that's top down imposed this is learning
is something that comes from within it's
also the difference between joy and
happiness many times I'm sad and I'm
still joyous and it's very very
important to understand the difference
between these externally
perceived success
paths and internally driven
value-based you know ways of being in
the world and we together when when we
combine all of these you know all of
these uh uh the broken puzzle let's say
of of of
substance and
um vulnerability we get this bigger
Gestalt this wondrous world of a future
that is is is
peaceful that is uh um that you know
that is wholesome and that that you know
that proposes or you know advocates for
that kind of synergy that we've been
talking about throughout but it's all
fun
uh well thank you for this incredible
conversation thank you for all the work
you're doing and I just have to say that
thank you for um noticing me and
listening to me you you're somebody from
from just today and from our exchanges
before this
like there's a sense where you care
about me as a human being which is in
which I could tell you care about other
humans thank you for doing that thank
you for having empathy and just like
um yeah really listening and noticing me
that I exist so thank you for that I've
been a huge fan of your work uh been a
huge fan of who you are as a human being
it's just an honor that you would sit
with me thank you uh thank you and uh as
long as I feel the same way I'll just
say the same and I look forward to
hearing the response to my job
application that I've submitted oh
you're you're accepted oh damn we all
speak of you all the time thank you so
much thank you thank you